hi I'm Paul Dietrich for reason TV we're
outside the Democratic National
Convention talk to people today about
big government and big business and the
relationship between the two of them we
talked to occupy wall streeters we
talked to the delegates on the inside
the Democratic National Convention and
we asked them if President Obama is the
person that can fix this relationship
we're here in Charlotte North Carolina
the location of the democratic national
convention but it's also the second
largest financial center in the United
States how do you feel about that I
didn't know that that's the first I've
heard of it I didn't know that yes no
wonder they have so many beautiful
buildings here it's very telling of the
Democratic Party shows it for their
convention site because the Democratic
Party just like the Republican Party is
in bed with the bankers and corporations
the bailout went to that bank over there
we're referring to bank of america so
like we didn't get a piece of that we
didn't get none of it President Obama
gave 45 billion dollars to bank of
america in 2009 how do you feel about
that and bank of america's presence here
well you know that's okay that's all
right because it kept a lot of people
employed he did what he should do the
President did what he should do to stop
this conflagration I really don't don't
even like to refer to it as a relief or
bailing out I mean I was just stepped
for then the banks to need a bailout it
just was another way for them to figure
out how can we how can we get the public
the public to give us more money I'm
down here because you know the two-party
system is a sham it's mainly a show the
money is still an honestly being donated
to both parties by people I think of
America and Duke Energy main players in
North Carolina seen leasing from
winston-salem yeah it's the hometown for
bank of america and also duke energy if
it is well it doesn't stop there there's
also duke energy this is also the
hometown him to them over there you just
saw energy well they have a booth they
also benefited from cap-and-trade
legislation so
good that's wonderful with legislation
there's always going to be some groups
that are helped by it and others that
are hurt by it create new jobs by doing
alternative energy that's part of this
policy so it's not like because you
contributed to me I'll give to you know
seems like that well due to the
uninformed okay okay it's part of the
policy to create I don't know so his
relationship with the business doesn't
doesn't bother you nope no it doesn't
I'm sure there's some things in there
and if i SAT there and I started reading
it and all that stuff you know yeah okay
then I'd be like oh man but a little bit
of bad isn't going to destroy the way I
feel about all the good that he does for
the general Americans if there anything
you want to say to the people inside of
the democratic national convention right
now um again don't believe the hype your
party's lying to you they're playing a
show this whole convention is a
made-for-tv movie that's all it is all
of this police is a made-for-tv movie
we're not that's not needed we're not
violent we're making a point